let's talk about the narrative breaking
we've got the story from nbc news marvel
actor evangeline lilly shares that she
attended axe
anti-vaccine mandate rally the
anti-vaccination mandate rally held
sunday made headlines because of
comments from robert f kennedy jr
comparing policies to the holocaust and
even after that
evangeline lilly was still willing to
publicly come out and be like yo i was
there because i believe in this
evangeline lily you rock you are awesome
you did a great job in ant-man and
ant-man and the wasp big fan and for you
to come out now and and stand up for
what you believe in in the face of of
this psychotic media going after
everybody smearing people lying about
people that is brave that is principled
i respect it and it shows for everybody
else you know when hollywood's
celebrities start coming out and saying
nah that's good news yep the narrative's
broken
yeah also i mean
of course you know holocaust comparisons
between the holocaust and events where
no one is being killed are so tired at
this point that even pointing out that
they're tired is tired
yeah people are losing their minds over
it but it's like everyone does it all
the time particularly i mean it happens
way more often on the left but
so so banal at this point but you know i
mean good for her for standing up for
the truth and being willing to say yeah
i was at this mandate these are my
actual values because there are a lot of
celebrities i'm sure who can see through
this stuff uh i i have some faith that
there are at least some of them who are
capable of it but they're just not
saying anything yeah it's um the
government jumped the shark that's that
that idea from like a tv show and the tv
show has just gone too far it's had too
many new adoptions of little kids to you
know whatever uh it comes from happy
days when i think they literally jumped
a shark on a motorcycle trying to one-up
themselves over and over get so far
they're like well the show's jumped the
shark the government's jumped the shark
we know it because we've been watching
and we can relate it to 20 years ago or
15 years ago but young kids that see it
aren't going to realize that this is too
far and they might think that it's
normal this is just how government works
evangeline lilly's got 2.2 million
followers and she posted a picture of
vax democrat for medical freedom
she said i was in dc this weekend to
support bodily sovereignty while
canadian truckers were rallying for
their cross-country peaceful convoy in
support of the same thing yo this is
epic i believe nobody should ever be
forced to inject their body with
anything against their will under threat
of violent attack arrest or detention
without trial loss of employment
homelessness starvation loss of
education alienation from loved ones
excommunication from society under any
threat whatsoever this is not the way
this is not safe it is not healthy this
is not love i understand the world is in
fear but i don't believe that answering
fear with force will fix our problems i
was pro-choice before covent i i'm still
pro-choice today bravo evangeline lily
that was an epic post and brave that is
you know what you know you know you know
what guys stunning and brave indeed yes
yes it is it was all based until that
last sentence but you know which i'm
glad
i hear what she's saying and it's great
because these are the people who want to
spend all of their time claiming that
they stand with the working class and
then when you have truckers who are
working class and are in many ways like
quite literally the backbone of the
economy if there's one group you're
going to point to and say we can make a
solid case that we absolutely need these
people it's truckers and so for them to
be thrown under the bus
and
for us to look the other way especially
people on the left who are constantly
constantly harping on about like how
empathetic they are and how much they
care about the working class is
ridiculous so good for her i mean she's
doing what they claim they're supposed
to do well and ian to your point on
jumping the shark and and passing the
moment like i think biting him first of
all let's flash you know back in time
when the bite administration used to say
oh yeah we can't do a mandate that's
just something we can't do legally
and then lo and behold they put the
mandate in place but lo and behold the
supreme court says no actually you can't
and now they're repealing their osha
mandate so i think even i mean the wave
is crested as far as the mandates are
concerned and i have to say this was an
anti-mandate rally which is contrary to
what i think it was cnn or msmc i forget
what i said they said it was an
anti-vaccine rally i'm like no you
obviously don't understand this is about
the mandates no they don't they're just
lying of course exactly
liars they are they're like thank you
for the correction
you know you know i'm i'm watching this
and we have uh marvel references and
what just comes to mind with the
mainstream narrative is that scene from
the new spider-man movie where doctor
strange is trying to contain the spell
but it's out of control and it just
erupts and i'm like that that is the
that is the truth that is reality and
they're desperately trying to contain it
and it just breaks free and then it
shatters the multiverse and then you
know reality comes breaking through not
in that movie i don't know if my bunch
of weirdos showed up like spider-man
from other movies but my point is the
narrative can't be contained they're
trying as hard as they can it's an
anti-vaxx protest of racists and and
white supremacists and then evangeline
lilly is just like nah that's why you
got to stay alive all of you it's
important right now as hard as things
might seem stay alive because it is
shattering and twisting open this is
inevitable
yeah well i mean i think there's there's
really cause for hope here the fact that
they have to tie themselves into knots
over this when they have to lie about
how large your movement is and how large
the protests are in a lot of ways you're
in good shape it's a good problem to
have it really is because people are
waking up to it imagine the alternative
imagine if we had to pretend that our
protests were far larger than they were
whoever has to lie about the numbers is
losing trump always
was like
huge
my reality they were huge his rallies
were massive so a lot a lot of them were
really big but i mean you know when they
come out after the inauguration
and it wasn't nearly that big it was big
and then they were like the biggest ever
it's like well if you include streaming
numbers then yes
but everybody's always trying to promote
themselves and i i certainly understand
why but the media does the opposite i
remember during i think it was during
occupy wall street this funny funny
thing happened where a local news
station was covering the one of the
protests like a peripheral protest in
some city and they the camera guy we
actually watched him wait until the end
of the protest and then start filming
when there was like seven people and
then there were like people were sharing
it look at this video of their report
and it was like the protest was quite
small and it shows like yeah that's what
they do no i so i remember when i was a
child my parents would sometimes take my
siblings and i to pray outside of either
abortion clinics or in one case christ
hospital because they were performing
abortions there despite the name of the
hospital and media came up
and started asking questions and as a
little child i'm not even like oh my
gosh what if they ask us questions and
we're going to be on tv and my dad says
shay they only go to old people they
only talk to the old people here they
don't want anyone to think that there
are young people interested in the
pro-life movement they have to curate a
very specific image about who's
interested in this
that sounds pretty legit oh my father's
very legit
we just keep doing what we're doing we
keep having a movement so strong that
they need to lie about how many people
believe in it i usually think like okay
if if this is true the narrative is
shattering and you know base reality is
coming back to fruition now it's our
chance to craft base reality we can
build that better what's it going to
look like you want to do a great reel
greater sheamus
i'm not in with this this world economic
forum thing
i wonder if this will precipitate some
uh other people coming out though you
know evangeline lilly is this is this
because we're seeing you know bill maher
barry weiss and other liberals now
signal to the left like hey it's safe
now you can come out of here big time
yeah that's the barry weiss thing i i is
maybe as cringe as you pointed out it
comes a year late i'm still glad it
happened because it's it was so high
profile the question is whether she's
going to get canceled
i don't know at this point
i mean
they might try but i don't think so
because her attitude is very defiant she
doesn't care you know what i mean it's
when when when people immediately become
demure and back down you know they don't
mean it but i mean it looks like she
really means it i think she i don't
think she just posted this this image i
think she made a video about it but let
me let me pull up her instagram and
we'll take we'll take a look
you know what else i'd kind of like to
suggest this i haven't looked into this
because the thought just came to me but
i would be curious to see how likely
these large studios are
to refuse to work with famous
celebrities when their stock price is
down
because right now the market's not doing
too great and i wonder if that gives
leverage to entertainers and performers
maybe but it does yeah well when the
industry is is flopping you know we had
uh christian toto on talking about
hollywood freaking out when when
hollywood's losing their power and
everyone's in panic because they're
aging out the movies aren't making as
much money
i mean
these these marvel movies are
blockbusters they're massive they're
billion dollar movies but the industry
itself it looks like it's in a downward
trajectory outside of that everything's
consolidating originality is is on the
decline you know wokeness it it maybe it
may be even that that people have
finally realized get will go broke yeah
there was a story about the new superman
comic i was reading from uh uh bounding
into comics the new superman comic where
superman's son is is bisexual it sold
like half what the other one sold
now i don't know we talked about it some
were saying it's because the the the the
companies
decide to sell less to a comic book
store something like that but i'm like
okay maybe i can't i don't know the
nitty-gritty of this but i do know that
people are complaining about they don't
want to buy it you know if the fans
don't like it they don't buy it so maybe
that stuff's having an impact and now
people uh
hollywood celebrities might just be like
it doesn't matter anymore because this
whole narrative on the left is
ineffective it loses money when you look
at
and it could even be as simple as joe
biden's approval rating people look and
they're like democrats are not popular
and they're retiring in mass i'm jumping
[ __ ] before it's too late also like you
said earlier carrie the omicron changed
the
the
the terrain it basically changed the
layout of what's going on with with
covet it's it's a less deadly
more contagious or i don't even know is
it it's endemic
yeah yeah it's more contagious it's it's
uh more mild but uh to your point on
hollywood the chosen and if if y'all
haven't seen the chosen you need to see
the chosen it's free you guys know about
the chosen i've heard good things okay
so the chosen is a serial uh video
series about the life of christ and it
was the most successful crowdfunded
movie project ever
and it was just christians who wanted to
have the story of jesus told uh and that
you know it's with acting and it's just
very well done it's incredible the
details uh it's it's so it's sort of
like fan fiction but it's actually you
know based on the bible not making a
bunch of stuff up um
but uh they then because the cereal like
they they released it basically like a
tv um series they then decided to do a
christmas special in
box office and it actually this chris
this past christmas season just came out
in box office it actually the opening
weekend per theater shattered all the
big hollywood films including they they
defeated on revenue poor theater house
of gucci which was like this you know
huge money suck um so it was incredible
and and that just shows and i actually
interviewed the the um executive
producer of the chosen i said how did
you guys slay the giant here i like how
did you guys do this and um they said
well it it's just the content and and i
said well i'm sure now at this point as
you were so successful you've been
approached by big houses and he said
yeah but we're not we're not gonna
surrender we're not gonna give that up
because they're they're gonna try to
pervert what we wanna
preach which is the gospel of jesus uh
and they're giving away for free and and
their goal is to to have it in in the
hands i think of two billion people i
mean they've already had you know
hundreds of millions of people have
viewed this so it's incredible yeah good
for them we were sort of speaking about
hollywood and the fact that they're
failing and i think obviously a huge
reason why new companies like this are
becoming successful is because there's a
niche in the market that needs to be
filled people don't want to be preached
at or ironically even when they do want
to be preached at least want it to be
entertaining and i think there are
obviously ways of spreading christian
morals and messages that don't come off
as preaching which are genuinely
entertaining now when it comes to
whether traditional hollywood is going
to be able to turn this spiral around
and climb back up i think the answer is
probably no and the reason that i'm
saying that it's not just out of a sense
of optimism here and i could be wrong
but i don't think this is a group of
people who on the individual level are
interested in success i believe because
of their ideology they see themselves as
victims and they're satisfied
complaining about how corrupt the system
is when they fail so they don't need to
get a taste of success i i think these
are you know uh when it comes to
hollywood when it comes to the
establishment left in the media these
are people who are only satisfied if
someone else tells them they're worthy
so that's why they all just virtually
signal to each other but eventually that
group becomes so broken and just brittle
that they have no choice but to seek
validation outside of that exactly so i
think that's part of what we're seeing
you know look for for evangeline lily to
come out and say this is amazing and
it's glad to see it's happening among
celebrities who is there first is the
question you know who who are the people
that were always standing up for
people's rights that always stood on
principle never back down never
questioned it
i mean those are the people of true
principle so i can certainly say thank
you to everybody who's coming around
being like we were wrong about this it's
good to admit you were wrong or if you
never spoke up about it speaking up
about it now it's a good thing thank you
for joining the fray but i think it's
important to to you know
keep that eye out some people are just
looking for validation and if they can't
get it anymore because their site has
gone nuts they'll just pretend like they
want validation from you
or or at least they do want it and
they're desperate for any kind of of
adoration you know people who don't know
how to think for themselves so they just
say to you you know
tell me what to say tell me what to
think thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you